let's talk about the the ramifications
of you know mass money printing and all
this stuff i have the story from axios
the wild ride of pandemic consumer
prices
i find it interesting that they just
they say it's the pandemic right
as opposed to what's been going on in
this country for some time when you
uh so we've looked at the m1 money stock
quite a bit and some sometimes m2 i'm
not
i'm not you guys know better than i do
but uh you can see around 2008
there's a major uptick in you know the
money stock and then
at the pandemic massive spike so i think
this this kind of stuff's been happening
for a long time
but they show us laundry detergent i'm
sorry laundry equipment is up 29
car and truck rentals 24 major
appliances 19
propane kerosene firewood 15 pork chops
11.
used cars and trucks are up 10 then
there's weird stuff like
women's dresses are down 14 public
transportation is down 15.
men's suits are down telephone hardware
is actually down 20 which is interesting
and airline fares have dropped
dramatically
i think that's for obvious reasons but
uh just to point out lumber prices have
skyrocketed
steel has skyrocketed there's a shortage
of a lot of computer equipment so we've
been trying to
we've been waiting now for over a month
to get a new computer for for the studio
right and we keep getting told from
everybody hard to come by can't get it
sorry
it's been particularly difficult prices
are going way up
yeah there yeah well and you mentioned
computer components and the price
they're saying is going down
but that's actually if you dig into it a
lot of times it's a lie for example if
the phone they'll say
it's twice as fast as the phone that you
bought two years ago they'll say that
means that the price has dropped by 50
percent
even though you still paid the amount
the same amount right thousand dollars
they say actually it's
it's 50 cheaper because it's twice as
fast and that's what they cook into
their books and then when they govern
the bureau of labor statistics reports
the cpi numbers
the numbers are cooked they're rigged
they to show an outcome that they have
pre-configured they want to show 1.6
or whatever the number is and they do
whatever they can to hedonically adjust
these numbers to get to that number
because they have an incentive to keep
the reported inflation as low as
possible
all right so i'm i'm i'm sure that
you're both bitcoin trillionaires yeah
at this point uh but but for the first
we're in it for the technology
but for the for the for the regular
people right regular people right now
who have been working 40 hours a week
they've been they've been getting paid
and they're watching people get paid 16
bucks an unemployment
yeah the people that are seeing all the
stuff the price is increasing what do
they need to know and what what what do
you think
people should look out for well the
inflation's here
uh it's a secular move in inflation it's
not going to be temporary it's going to
be
now structurally baked into the economy
and prices are going to start to go up
on a regular basis and the re the reason
why i wasn't as visible as it has been
with all the money printing that has
gone on is that
essentially jobs were shipped over to
china
and that kept the numbers low for a long
time because
there was no wage pressure but now since
the middle class in china has equaled
more or less middle class in america you
don't really have that the sink
of cheap labor anymore right so now
prices are going to start
moving up in reflection of their actual
money supply numbers
for real and that's what people are
seeing so one key
statistic and this is true is that once
the price the um budget of the average
family once uh they allocate 40
to food that's when you usually see an
insurrection so we saw it in egypt
when price got to 40 there was a
revolution
we saw it in france the french
revolution the food cost got to around
40
in the u.s uh for a vast majority of
folks we're now bumping into that
we're getting now approaching that 40
number so that would indicate
historically that you're getting
close to a flash point where an
insurrection would become um
historically the norm
wow you're also like that's scary
all those things you're talking not
really did you guys buy like a mountain
bunker in new zealand or something it's
normal i mean
you know things happen and uh
cycles happen and the thucydides trap as
you mentioned that's going to lead to
deglobalization you're already seeing
the deglobalization that causes prices
to rise
you have the fourth turning uh this
young generation the generation z
aren't going to do you think they're
really going to um
give 80 of their wages over to the
retired boomers no they're not going to
right
no why i wouldn't they have the numbers
as well so
they're going to just you know tell them
to stick it
then um the in terms of the inflation
numbers
yeah you like we're at the end of that
cycle as well we're at the end of the
dollar the triphen dilemma
has reached the end game and you see
that with
the extraordinary amount of money i mean
max and i have been reporting on
the global financial crisis since 2008
2009
and the stuff they're doing now is just
beyond any of that right
it's like if you look at the charts of
of the money printing and the
interventions in the economy
now versus 2008 um
it's like it's beyond anything it's so
ridiculous and yet
you know we're still in the krakow boom
side of it like things are like stock
markets are at
all-time highs house prices at all-time
highs
like incomes are up 20 over 20
in the last year for the ordinary
american incomes are up 20
most of it from the uh government
transfers so
you know these are crack up boom times
and they're printing more and more
like you're supposed to do the money
printing that the theory is
under canes is you're not supposed to do
that during the crack up boom times
you're supposed to wait for the crash
but they're not even waiting for the
crash anymore are they again getting
back to this green span put or the
machinations of the plunge protection
team or the government in terms of
markets is that they would not allow for
a normal business cycle to take place
yes where you have a downturn and then
you get rid of that for example the
banks in 2008 were caught
committing massive fraud and so in a
normal capitalist economy a business
cycle those banks would have had to go
bankrupt
and we would have had new banks and new
jobs and but instead they bailed out the
creditors they bailed out the banks
again historically you never see that
usually in a
crisis like that the debtors get bailed
out the people who are at the mortgages
and the debit credit cards would get
bailed out not the
not the banks who made the fraudulent
loans right they got bailed out
and what they did with that what let's
call it 16 trillion dollars of bailout
money when it's all said and done
is they simply were allowed to expand
their credit card
expand their credit facilities and do
the exact same things that caused the
crisis in 2008
but to do it 10 times to 20 times bigger
and 20 times worse
and we've been saying now for 10 years
that you know that what's going to
happen in 10 to 12 years
is the is going to be the 2008 crisis
part 2 and that's exactly what we're in
now it's just the same crisis from 2008
the the global economy died in 2008 but
now it's getting
buried now it's like a it's like a lich
is that how you say it yeah
that's one way to say it you know it's
like an undead like just
reanimated course well how many zombie
companies are there in the united states
something like 30 percent of the s p 500
are companies that
can't really afford to pay interest on
the debt that they carry on their books
from their earnings they're technically
zombies they're dead companies they're
the walking dead and that's like a third
of all the s p
500 and they're just kept alive by free
money printing it's just like money
money money money
what's amazon just announced today that
they're going to float
billions of dollars of the bonds guess
what to do what to buy back their own
stock
is what's going to happen so here again
it's zero percent money
uh for some which is incredibly um
you know dangerous for example when
amazon bought whole foods it was
accretive from day one
they cost them nothing they bought it
for nothing when um
tiffany was bought by lvmh in europe
they bought tiffany
how much did they pay to buy tiffany a
multi-billion dollar company they paid
exactly nothing
because the european central bank lent
them all the money they needed this
central bank to buy tiffany's with no
interest they gave them tiffany's as a
gift
they're already the biggest luxury
company in the world it just kind of
sounds like fascism
it's a corporatism but also like it's
important to
point out that in the past year we've
done fiscal stimulus
so since 2008 it's been um just federal
reserve stimulus and that's credit to
the banking system
so it's not cash this is cash this is
what they've been printing the the
trillions of dollars
that the u.s government is printing that
is high velocity
real money that is what causes the big
inflation
yeah yeah right so so uh is this why you
guys were saying by bitcoin
like back in the day we were gold bugs
into in 2011
and then we were introduced to bitcoin
and we immediately
realized that this was digital hard
money i have a background
in virtual currencies going back to the
mid 90s i created the hollywood stock
exchange which
created i invented a digital currency in
1996
i have a patent on that digital currency
so i immediately recognized that this
could do what we were trying to get that
to do back in the mid 90s
and um so we went from gold over to
bitcoin
and it's kind of like when dylan went
electric
so we i i'm gonna i'm we're gonna have
to come back to this conversation so put
a pin because we got we got breaking
news lydia just pulled this up
this is from uh bloom bloomberg law is
this this is from bloomberg law
yeah gas stations running dry as hacked
pipeline tries to restart
so yeah we were worried actually on the
drive up here because i was i was like
guys yeah we've got this little bunker
you know we put some cotton
they've got some hammocks and there's
beans that's right and we got a lot of
mres
just because they're fun yeah but do you
have mre gasoline
no i do have an electric car
okay and my van is is solar powered
so in the apocalypse i can actually plug
my electric car
into the uh the the solar power from the
van yeah
and in probably about two or three weeks
you'll be able to drive the electric car
well look this is a function of too much
debt
so um the infrastructure is breaking
down and yet before
the up until a few years ago you had
this just-in-time economy
where things were logistically all
connected you had globalization
and you had this incentive to keep all
these systems going at the absolute rock
bottom cheapest price and to not pay
anybody anything
in terms of a decent wage but once the
um
thucydides trap kicks in once the u.s
dollar loses its status as world reserve
currency
then it would it reveals all the
shortcomings in the system and it
reveals all the fragility in the system
and there's suddenly no way to
repair these uh infrastructure projects
because the money is being
sent out directly from the treasury to
appease the rabble rousers from
staging an insurrection i mean this is
what they do in countries where they pop
with the population's about to insurrect
is they try to throw money at them to
appease them and that works for a short
period of time and then it doesn't work
so how much time do you got left
well every every time you read a story
like that like oh you know we ran out of
microchips so the cards that aren't
being delivered
oh gas lines and not being restarted
can't get gas oh the
price of food is not 40 of my weekly
budget right you add all those data
points up
and every day you get new data points so
it's it's tough to say exactly when the
pot boils but it's
happening but i say get ready for good
times because you know this
stuff has to end for the next generation
to have their way right right the night
is always darkest before the dawn
yeah it's good for millennials and you
know that great century
uh yeah and the generation z who are
like 25 years old now
uh the oldest ones and that in terms of
those microchips you know
you had been talking about cycles and
and the business cycle
that used to exist when max and i were
you know your age
we had the business cycle and the thing
about the semi
conductor chips is they you know they
never
they never planned nobody expected the
money printing
like the fiscal stimulus right so what
happened is naturally these business
executives saw a pandemic saw
global lockdown and they cancelled their
orders they said we don't need we're not
going to need those cars because we're
on lockdown right
nope they didn't expect the thousands
and thousands of dollars to be thrown at
everybody and everybody to go on a
buying spree so
there were backlogs like everybody all
these auto companies had cancelled their
orders
expecting that things would be slowing
down
and across the board computers phones
all that stuff every
everything that you use as a microchip
they were not expecting
so much money it sounds like there's two
there's two things i'm kind of hearing
from what you guys are saying the first
is that there are people who decided the
ship's sinking extract as much as you
can before it goes down and
bail yourself out but the other thing is
you know i mentioned the fascism thing
because when you say like the central
banks are giving this money to like
amazon to buy whole foods or whatever
it sounds like the government is
surreptitiously
empowering massive corporate monopolies
to seize power
totally it's not even the government
it's a private corporation these these
companies have no oversight the federal
reserve the bank of international
settlements
well because um this is why they say
that the inflation is let's say running
at 1.6 percent
even though if you were to calculate
inflation as you would do under the
clinton administration
and without using all these hedonic
adjustments inflation actually right now
is running 10 to 12
that's the real number 10 to 12 that's
what it's really happening is that per
year
per dollar per year so now they say it's
1.6
so why do they openly lie because for
two reasons the
cola adjustments the cost of living
adjustments for social security so they
save about 70 billion
a year by not paying out what they
should be paying out because inflation
is going high
to social security benefits the other
but the primary reason is that by saying
that
inflation's running low and in flat
claiming that there's deflation
they can justify lower interest rates
that are near zero
which are what powers all the
consolidation that tiffany being bought
hopefully being bought
mergers and acquisition and when i said
earlier about infrastructure crumbling
because of all the debt to finish up on
that point a little bit
it goes back to private equity what
private equity does private equity can
borrow all this money
at near zero percent and buy entire
companies to tie our industries
and strip out all the assets and keep
the profits like uh
um you know bain the bain capital uh
mitt romney
uh you know that's his one what's where
he comes from you know we saw it in the
movie in wall street in the 1980s right
they were doing a leveraged buyouts as
it was called
uh well that what does that mean what is
that that means that if you have a
company and you want to buy that company
what you can do is and i was working on
wall street when this really became
huge is that you can pledge the assets
of the company that you don't own
to borrow money and then you borrow the
money and you buy the company that you
previously did not own and now that you
own it you start to
sell the assets off the pension fund the
overfunded pension account the real
estate
all they fire everybody and what's left
and you pay down the debt that you
borrowed
and you keep what's left which could be
100 million or half a billion dollars
that's
a leverage buyout and it was um really
pioneered by mike milken
during the 1980s because he he he wrote
a paper when he was a wharton
where he figured out that the lower
grade debt
outperforms high grade debt you know so
he said you know what why don't we just
do original issue
low-grade debt so ron perlman and all
these other corporate raiders as they
were known they went to mike milken
they borrowed billions they did leverage
buyouts they bought these companies
and they sold they stripped them they
sold all the assets and they became
billionaires well
over the last 30 years that's become
bigger and bigger and bigger and so the
private equity market like
warren buffett is essentially a private
equity firm he doesn't invent anything
he doesn't do anything he never worked a
day in his life
he just borrows money cheap from the fed
strips companies he's an asset stripper
that's all he does
and he's overrated as a mar as a
performer if you take out the bailouts
from the warren buffett performance over
the past 30 years he wouldn't be beating
a money market fund he's the most
overrated money manager in history
so uh people like to say when we're
talking about you know
iras or metal or bitcoin this is not
financial advice
the first thing i want to ask you a
question i haven't given any financial
advice on this program tim so i just
wanted to ask real quick why is that why
i would never do that why would people
say
this is not like why do people do that
because you have to be licensed to give
financial advice
and so people can interpret what you're
saying as advice is what it is
yeah because then they could claim that
you were offering advice and they
lost money let's say and then you're
saying okay you
you gave me unlicensed financial advice
but you've you've mentioned you know
that people should buy bitcoin haven't
you
yeah because it's not it's i'm saying
bitcoin is
a substitute for gold and it's a
substitute for the dollar this this came
up recently because a lot of journalists
are saying they don't write about
bitcoin
because um they consider it to be a
conflict
in some way because they don't own it
bitcoin they wouldn't own bitcoin and
write about bitcoin etc
but we're talking about a substitution
for the base layer of money from dollars
to bitcoin
so it's not a financial advice it's
about advice about how to
reconfigure the entire economy the
united states economy the global economy
on a bitcoin
standard and so we've been saying this
since it was a dollar back in 2011
and um we also talked about gold if you
talk about gold
gold is an intricate part of the global
financial picture so
countries buy gold the central banks own
30 000 tons of gold you talk about gold
you can say you own gold it's an
inflation hedge here's a way to
inflate against inflation is gold
so bitcoin is the new gold it's digital
gold it started in 2011 and we talked
about it
so it's we're making that point that
this is what it is
and that's what we've been saying the
reason i ask is because you mentioned
inflation
was actually at 10 to 12 percent for
real yeah which
shouldn't that like make people act as
other pants are on fire kind of freak
out
that's that's that's scary they should
and they the people who have
with the price of bitcoin at 55 000 per
coin
is telling you that the us dollar right
now is in a hyper inflationary collapse
against
bitcoin that's what the price is telling
you bitcoin is really the only market in
the world that's allowed to trade freely
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you